لم يشتغل
هذا اليوم هو يوم احتفال
بالمحاربين القدامى في الولايات المتحده
وللنجينا من الحروب الذين سوف يبقون بصمه
لا تنسى في الولايات المتحده وهذا اليوم
وفي كل الايام لابد لنا ان نشد بكل من
ضحوا بحياتهم من اجل البلاد اود ان اشكر
احد المحاربين القدماء وهو موظف قديم
وتجمعني معه علاقه طيبه
المبعوث الخاص للمناخ السيد جون كيري
[تصفيق]
جون
ان شغفكم
ودبلومس دبلوماسيه
جوهريه في احراز تقدم من في مجال المناخي
خلال السنتين الماضيين شكرا جزيلا هنا في
مصر
[موسيقى]
بالعالمتنا في وجه الكوارث وننظروا الى
اقتصاداته
الاقتصادات التي تعتمد على الطاقه النظيفه
وفقا ووفقا لمنظمه الارصاد الجويه فان
سنوات العشرين الماضيه شهدت تغيرا ملحوظا
في ارتفاع درجات الحراره وكذلك الولايات
المتحده عاشت جفافا كان قد اثر عليها فضلا
عن الاعصارات التي ضربت في الشرق وهنا في
افريقيا موطن لدول كثيره التي تعدوا
الاكثر ضعفا في وجه التغير المناخي وهناك
حاله من الجوع
مستشريه
بالاضافه الى
اسوان
الجفاف الذي ضرب القرن الافريقي هو هذا
كله يحدث يحدث ويلات كبيره وفي نيجيريا
الاحداث المناخيه الاخيره قتل 600 شخص
واكثر من مليون شخص في اعداد النازحين
كذلك ايضا قد تم استخدام الماشيه لسنوات
كثيره لكنها تراجعت الامر الذي يصعب على
المزارعين واصحابي المشاهدين ان ازمه
المناخ تتعلق بالامن الانساني وبالامن
الاقتصادي وبالامن البيئي
والامن القومي
وحياتي الكوكب بعينه لذا اليوم اود ان
اشاطر معكم كيف الولايات المتحده سوف تعمل
على التصدي لتغير المناخي بصوره عاجله
وجعل بيئتنا اكثر امنا وسلامه لنا جميعا
منذ هو اليوم الاول الذي تربعت فيه في
سجده السلطه كانت قضيه المناخ على الجدول
اعمالي وشدته على مساله معالجتها في داخل
البلاد وفي كافه انحاء العالم وانضممنا
الى اتفاقيه باريس مجددا وقمنا ايضا بعقد
قمه المناخ
واعتذر اذا كنا قد انسحبنا من هذه
الاتفاقيه وقمنا ايضا بعقد منتديات متعدده
من اجل الدفع بطموحنا نحو المنى
للولايات المتحده
بشان الحد من الانبعاثات الى واحد فاصل
خمسه مليون درجه مئويه وفي الولايات
المتحده قدم
كبيره
صنع الشبكات الكهرباء بحيث يتم نقل الطاقه
النظيفه